very much Ted
well we're going to stay on that topic
because new at six Rising food prices
the turkey shortage meets families are
also looking for alternative ways to
have that Thanksgiving meal and Mary
Jane belly as uh has some options for
families look at a save this year
gathering at the table is a bit more
expensive this year with high food costs
on the menu as many families deal with
inflation and food shortages according
to the American Farm Bureau Federation
the average cost this year for a turkey
is almost 30 dollars a 21 increase from
last year Brian slipbock the owner of
Jackson's Bar and Grill has been
preparing for the Thanksgiving Rush
since October people say hey I can't
find a turkey or it's too expensive and
by the time I had everything else in as
you know as far as the side order the
side dishes it's just too expensive for
them so we've been getting a lot of
calls about coming in flipbox says you
can't beat the price at just 20 bucks a
plate which comes with turkey breast and
all the fixings he expects it to be
busier than years past and he's already
getting a head start on planning
Christmas meals inflation the supply
chain getting the food in everything
like that people wanting to be with
family and not spending time away from
them in the kitchen
uh it's gonna make us and every
restaurant in town a lot busier that
includes Station Casinos As It prepares
to dish out over 200 take-home meals for
Thanksgiving we always have hundreds go
out every year we've noticed it's a good
addition to the community along with
coming to our resorts to have that
Thanksgiving feeling from all the family
Vibes we offer Joe yalda the vice
president of guest experience at Red
Rock Casino says a variety of their
restaurants like Lucille's barbecue and
lucky penny will have a Thanksgiving
feast the reservations are available
still at all of our restaurants and if
you're the type of person that actually
wants a home-cooked meal we're offering
Thanksgiving to go from Green Valley
Ranch and so those start at 300 and that
and feeds up to people up to eight
people and then also includes two pies
Mary Jane belyaza 8 news now
Jackson's Bar and Grill is taking
walk-ins for Thanksgiving and if you
would like to order a Thanksgiving meal
from Station Casinos we have that
information you'll find it on our
website over at 8newsnow.com